my name is Leonard Turner I am with the
Central Intelligence Agency and I have
been taken hostage
in approximately 14 hours they'll have
control over the world to
telecommunications if their demands are
not met all missile silos will be
activated with cornice said continental
United States / - dad
sir I want to be a part of it your goal
is to get your father back my goal is to
protect the freight world those goals
are the same we'll take it from here
agent Turner sir go home son all right
sorry about the way that's going down me
too
sir just activated ages Europe and South
America on communication they have a
terrorist faction in the southeastern
United States
where are the missile codes you tell me
when I walk on out of here I missed you
too
so what's the plan get inside and ask
them where the codes are you have no fan
works in the movies take the shot
I'm never threatened my family
now was that so hard
busy day
the dance I promised unknown to the
finder invested Mark IV